the playstation 5 reveal event has
wrapped and we got our first look at the
console and a ton of games coming soon
let's break down all the big
announcements from the stream first
we'll talk about the console itself it
has a white design that matches the new
dual Sense controller and it comes in
two SKUs one is standard and the other
called the digital edition has no disk
drive sony unfortunately did not
announce a price for either console but
it did reveal some additional
accessories the PS 5 is also getting a
media remote dual Sense charging stand
3d audio headset and a new camera to be
used with the psvr so let's talk games
now there were a bunch of hot sequels
and franchises you may have been
expecting to see during the stream we're
getting a new Ratchet and Clank call
drift apart a Spider Man sequel starring
Miles Morales and a follow-up to the
playroom called Astros playroom NBA 2k
21 and Gran Turismo 7 aren't surprising
but they were both shown off Resident
Evil 8 village and horizon forbidden
West were also finally confirmed after a
long run at the rumor mill then there's
hitman 3 coming in January 2021 last but
definitely not least a Demon Souls
remake has been confirmed there were
also a ton of games that aren't tied to
an existing franchise these include
Square Enix is project a Thea guerrillas
return 'el sumo digital sackboy a big
adventure
Capcom's pragmatic and bug snacks from
the makers of Octodad we also saw stray
destruction all-stars kehna bridge of
spirits goodbye volcano high and jet the
far shore of course PS 5 is getting a
bunch of previously announced games too
including Grand Theft Auto 5 solar ash
little devil inside ghost wire Tokyo and
death loop meanwhile God fall got a new
trailer that was the first confirmed PS
5 game from last year's Game Awards so
that's 25 confirmed games for Sony's hot
new consoles so far we are still waiting
to hear how much the PS 5 will actually
cost so stay tuned a game spot for more
information on that we're gonna learn a
whole lot more before it launches this
holiday season
[Music]